Speaker 1: So I don't have good news to start with
today. Today we have to start talking seriously,
I mean, listen, I could lie to you, I could
come to you and say 2022 is looking great
for Democrats. It's looking great for the left.
But it's not. 2022 is looking disastrous. And
we're going to look at every data point or most
data points that we have now. And then I'm going
to talk about what could change the direction of
2022. But it it's not looking good. Democrats are,
if nothing changes, and that's a key part of it
if nothing changes. Democrats are heading towards
a possibly historic crushing by Republicans in
the 2022 midterms. Now, historically, when one
party takes the White House in the immediate first
midterm, it's not typically great for that party.
So because Joe Biden took the White House from
a Republican in 2020, we would expect it's not
pointing to being great for Democrats in 2022,
but it's looking particularly poor now. There are
some Democrats that are sounding the alarm, and
it's angering some on the left, even if they're
basically right in what they're saying. Elizabeth
Warren is one such Democrat Elizabeth Warren, now
on multiple shows appearing and saying Democrats
are going to lose in 2022 if we don't deliver
more. Elizabeth Warren delivered a warning on
Sunday, saying if they don't get up and deliver
while their party has the majority, they
will lose. Quote There's so much we can do,
and if we do it over the next 200 days, we're
going to be in fine shape. Take it to the people
what we've done. I think we're going to be in
real trouble. If we don't get up and deliver,
then I believe that Democrats are going to lose.
Now what she's saying, kind of like generically,
is fine. If we do stuff people like will win,
and if we don't, then we're going to lose.
But she's increasingly using this language because
she sees the writing on the wall. And what is the
writing on the wall? Well, every sign looks bad
for Democrats, and we can go through some of
them first and foremost. How popular is Joe Biden
now? There are some headlines that say, Oh my God,
Joe Biden in the low 30s approval. We look at an
average of polling, and if you look at an average,
Biden's approval has ticked up just a hair
from like 41 and a half to closer to 43
over the last month. But it's not good, and we've
looked at these historical numbers before. If you
compare Joe Biden to past presidents, he's
now as unpopular as Trump was at this point
in Trump's presidency. He's less popular than
Obama. He's less popular than George W. Bush.
He's less popular than Clinton. He's less popular
than George H.W. Bush. Slightly less popular than
Reagan, about as popular as Jimmy Carter. OK,
so we're going back really far now to find a
president that at this point in their first term,
was this unpopular? In a sense, midterms are a
referendum on the president, whether they should
be or not. And so that's not particularly good.
If you look at a generic ballot, do voters want
Democrats or Republicans in pot in Congress right
now? Republicans have about a two and a half point
advantage in a generic ballot. Now the problem is
that because of gerrymandering, which favors
Republicans big picture at the national level,
this small advantage for Republicans,
which is growing a little bit, by the way,
might significantly favor Republicans when it
comes to the House because of gerrymandering.
If we look at predicted predicted is where you
can bet on different elements of politics. The
question who will be speaker of the House next
Congress, which the speaker is a member of the
party that's in control, 70 cents of every dollar
is going behind it. Being Kevin McCarthy, who will
be speaker of the House and then nine cents is
going to Steve Scalise. Both are Republicans,
meaning 79 cents of every dollar. In fact, it's
more because Jim Jordan's getting five cents and
Donald Trump is getting four cents and Elise
Stefanik is getting three cents. So 79, 84,
88, 91 cents of every dollar are going to it's
going to be a Republican speaker of the House.
That's not good now. Betting markets aren't
polls, but that's the point. Betting markets are
where do I put my money when it comes to what
I think will happen, not what I want to happen.
Also on predicting what will be the balance
of power after twenty twenty to 75 cents of
every dollar is going to, it will be both a
Republican House and Senate. So these these
numbers are not looking particularly good, and
then lastly, the Politico forecast says the
Senate is leaning Republican, whereas the House
is likely Republican. So this is very, very,
very bad. Now, could everybody be wrong? Well,
I think the question is, could things change
between now and when the people start voting,
which is in just a few months? But something has
to happen. Number one, there's this old phrase
it's the economy stupid. And when you and I,
if we soberly look at the economy, the economy's
actually doing OK. Yes, there's high inflation,
but it looks like it's peaking and it will start
to decline. Gas prices have been high, but they're
already starting to decline. Unemployment, we
are very close to full employment. What about
wages? That's always a question. But we are
very close to full employment, if not there.
The stock market very shaky, and it could
be on its way to a downturn. But the stock
market is it's still nearly high, historically
high levels. Most indicators are pretty good,
but Americans don't know it. We just did a
story a couple of weeks ago about a poll where,
like a third of Americans, think there have been
job losses. While Joe Biden has been president,
there have been dramatic job gains under
Biden. Now, of course, you can always say,
are they quality jobs? And you can always
ask those questions, but by the numbers we
typically accept to look at. There have been
massive job gains under Biden, and a third
of Americans think we've lost jobs. So it's not
the economy, it's the perception of the economy,
and many Americans think it's not so good. The one
thing I do want to mention the Supreme Court very
soon could be weeks at this could be four weeks
could be more like eight between four and eight
weeks from now. The Supreme Court is going
to make a ruling about a state abortion ban.
And if they uphold, I believe it's the Mississippi
law, it will effectively overturn Roe v. Wade,
which has been the law of the land, making
abortion legal in most cases for decades in the
United States. It would be terrible if the Supreme
Court did that. And I wonder, is that a catalyst
that could really motivate Democratic voters to
come out and say, we've got to do something about
this? I don't want that to happen. I want the
Supreme Court to make the right decision. But
if they don't and they effectively overturn Roe
v. Wade, what will that do in terms of motivating
Democrats to say, Well, I have to go and support
whoever it is at the state level? Governor Senate,
even if I don't think Joe Biden's been
fantastic because this is so important
women getting the right to decide for themselves
what they need to do. Taken away. So that's a
question mark. I would love to hear from you.
What else could happen between now and November
that would change what are very grim numbers
for Democrats? Let me know what you think